nó chỉ là 2 cái hình thức độc từ thôi
và không có hình thức nào hình cái hình thức nào cả
cái nào phụ hình thức thì chúng ta sẽ dục
có thể mà thì nó đơn phần nữa giải nó chỉ là mấy công cổ
để dục mọi người dưới tổn thị ra
mà vẫn tận dụng được sự găng trường
của thị trường tại chính thồ chúng ta đã hai phần biệt
các hình lục tự rửa giang tiết và trị tiếp
thì đồng thình lục tự qua của ý ra giang tiết
đồng thử giống là tự xây dựng của cái dành bộ phần thích
rửa trỏ của phiếu
là trị tiếp
và mà người rất là hai sau xanh ra hình thức này
nhưng mà người rất là hai sau xanh hình thức là các bạn để
tự xây này
mọi người rất là hai khên
và cho giang giói giang hơn khi mình tự trỏ lợi từng mạc vụ phiếu
bây giờ rất nhiều người em cho cái xây vụ khi này thì 3
cũng là không ai bỏ công giv kiểu với dân nhập cả
vì người khác nổi
vì trong cái kênh nhóm và gọi em cảm thấy
nó để sẽ là những cuộc phiếu mạc tým nạn
một thích rất là mơ hồ không có số địa thì cả
nó sẽ tăng chưa
trong khi đó lại chê những người hỏi phần thích rất là kiếp
về chân nó của khuy
về kể xanh hồ khuy
về các thêm nước phiếu của khuy và cái mức tự xói của khuy
để thị ăn nghĩ rất là nó không đồng cho làm
nó chỉ là hai cái hình thức độ từ thốt
nó không có hình thức mạc hơn tý hình
nó có cái nà phù hợp thì chúng ta sẽ dụng